josephina you grew up in romania
yes and so uh off camera you were
telling me some interesting things about
just movie going in general
uh during the time you were there
it's a lot to talk about it but i can
you know i can tell you
it was just you know it was censorship
going on a lot of censorship so
obviously
i didn't grow up with a lot of
uh hollywood movies that they're modern
basically i was watching a lot of
romanian movies they were made in
romania or other
uh communist made movies uh also more
like hollywood movies from the 40s
musicals and
dramas and things like that but not a
lot of
mainstream movies like you know rocky or
john hughes movies or things like that
that i had to
you know catch up with after i moved
here and also no horror movies
because those are forbidden during
communism
because the dictator that we had didn't
want to be
compared to one of the you know monsters
like dracula or frankenstein
from the horror movies but of course
people still compared him with that
so that's why he uh banned all the
horror movies
at the time so once again it's kind of
strange because i'm making horror movies
but i didn't grow up with them well
obviously i had a lot of catching up to
do
after i moved here and started to work
in the industry
was that one of the first things that
you did once you were able to watch
horror films or no it just kind of was a
natural it was a natural process
it's kind of it was kind of overwhelming
because we're going from one video store
to
another and like all these movies that i
wanted to watch for
you know a long time so i would watch
almost everything like we always watch a
movie a day but
obviously i wanted to catch up on horror
movies because my husband was making
horror movies so i wanted to
you know understand more of the genre
and then also i started to work
um on various independent productions in
the horror movies and
you work with people who have
interesting careers and resumes so
you want to watch their movies before
you interview for a job or once you
start working with them because i think
it's normal to be able to have a better
conversation with them and learn from
them
because they always give you examples so
what i did on this movie or that movie
but i think you should watch them
you know work first
so um and then you know more you uh
you dig into that i think it's an
interesting genre
and it's very widespread and um
for me i'm like at a level when i think
i
i love digging into like it's not just
about um
i have to do that it's something that i
enjoy and
i like to uh go more into obscure things
and it's a lot of learning to do because
i think you should know a lot
about the genre that you were making
movies uh
in and for me it's a very interesting
it's been a very interesting process
because it opened me up to
different possibilities sometimes people
put um
horror filmmaking kinda like almost like
in the ghetto of filmmaking
and i think that's wrong because if you
look at various
filmmakers or movies you can express
a lot of interesting ideas through
horror movies you can be political or
what's going on in the society at that
point
sure you might do it with zombies or
vampires or whatever but you can
do interesting things and also explore
the human nature and for me
you know with horror movies you can do
that definitely because
what i think it's interesting sometimes
it's not necessarily
about um sometimes scary for me it's not
necessarily monsters or vampires that
could be
it but it's more how we how human beings
treat each other
and that's something that i like to
explore in horror movies because
sometimes that can
get very scary sure and people's hidden
agendas and ulterior motives
absolutely absolutely that can be uh for
me more frightening than
you know fighting with a monster sure
so when you would go to the cinema when
you were in romania
uh what was that experience like in
terms of the audience
watching the film and engaging with it
you know people
loved movies um they're so thirsty for
that
and i remember being in lines especially
if it was an american movie because
sometimes they would have like let's
say kramer vs scram or something a bit
more innocent they would show that
well there were lines around the theater
and once you if you're lucky to get a
ticket
let's say later that afternoon or
something the theaters were full so
people
it was a lot of uh
love for movies and going to the movies
and also i grew up
um with an uncle who was a director of
photography so from
an early age i was either you know in
front of the camera behind the camera in
different
situations and i learned a lot and also
watched a lot from shorts to
anything i could you know see it was
possible
for me to see during that time period
and also later on it was also something
interesting once the
vhs era started we were having
pirated you know um vhs
uh tapes they were like literally it was
not like almost like a
hidden circuit and they were dubbed
by a romanian translator who became a
famous film critic nowadays it's even a
documentary
made about that era and how she was
dubbing movies and about this
underground
circuit and you know you could everybody
was just like so eager to watch
anything that it was kind of it's a
fascinating
era you know basically because something
gets banned
what happens people become more thirsty
for whatever that's forbidden so people
keep
trying to fight and they find ways to
see it you know
i mean i watched i remember i think it's
this meryl streep movie falling in love
totally dubbed
by this lady like the voice everybody
was speaking with the same
uh voice but you know what i didn't care
you know if a movie
transports you into another world it's
gonna happen no matter what
it was on pal like it was on pal yeah
basically i don't know it was literally
somebody from you know kgb like in
russia we had our own kgb
and what's strange somebody from was an
officer
in that kgb who had like a little
operation that was bringing tapes
from the west and had a little studio
and uh he was making transferring you
know
pal have hired this lady
to translate and dub them basically she
didn't even have time to watch the movie
she would just show up at this studio
put her you know headphones on and she
just start translated
right then and there so you know
obviously it's not like the best
translation
translation she was just doing the best
she could because she there was like so
much demand
that she couldn't you know watch the
movie take notes
translate all that she was just doing it
like almost
on the spot so that's kind of
an interesting thing and we were
watching these tapes and everybody was
making dub
from a dub and you watch aliens at some
you know some
friend of yours birthday party like that
and
you know everybody was you know it's not
like an underground like okay i'm giving
you aliens but don't tell that to
anybody okay and you know from then on
some people making dubs and
was growing but you know obviously in
the theaters uh
people were lining up and i mean i
watched you know sometimes a weird
double feature some
western from the 60s with some italian
cup movie from the 70s you know you
never
know and for me it's kind of
it's how i grew up so how does that
affect how you make movies now knowing
that if you try to
either conceal something or prevent
people from seeing it it's only going to
make them
want to see it more i guess it's just
human nature it is human nature well
you know what happened for us um with
um our last two movies high eight and
high def
is we have different filmmakers who live
and work in different parts of the u.s
creating a segment for these heart
ontologies
and one of the main things we wanted um
to create with this was give everybody
the creative freedom because people
think of
uh independent filmmaking in us and they
think of sundance or they think of
whatever they think not a whole lot but
probably what they think about is more
that they have in the they have creative
freedom and that's not the case we've
been made
making movies as independents for like
over 10 years now
and sometimes you just kind of do
whatever
your investor tells you to do or you try
to work with them
you come up with an idea but you kind of
have to put some actress in it that you
don't want or
make a zombie movie but you have
creative freedom but
you know you kind of start with their
concept so
it's not so much creative freedom for
independent
filmmakers all the time and we know that
in other filmmakers who work
in the united states they know that
they've dealt with all sorts of
interesting situations and we realized
that we're like
well let's create something that these
uh filmmakers
can do what they really wanna do
we're not gonna get involved in their
scripts and their ideas we're not gonna
tell them what to do
we have some rules that everybody have
to respect more like
on a technical level or just you know
uh to have more like an interesting
dogma style
um approach but they're gonna have
creative freedom so that's what we're
trying to do and that's something that
i think i'm kind of obsessed with
because i'm from europe i'm more about
um filmmakers being especially directors
being an author because i've seen how
much
interference there is in us and how many
directors sometimes they um are cut off
from editing room and you know i've
heard and witnessed all sorts of
situations so i
think it's important to give the
directors
their voice and that's something that i
probably carry too
from living you know under communism and
censorship for
you know 13 14 years of my life yeah
then you went to film school in france i
started i went to film school in romania
and then i got a scholarship in france
uh from like their um foreign affair
ministry and basically you have to do
some
tests and you know and yeah i made a
documentary like a short in
in france and then i came back and
finished my studies in
in romania and then started working in
romania for
various uh studios in production
so how was that from um knowing there
was a controlled message with cinema
to then going to france where was it was
it a very
um open place and very permissive in
terms of what was shown
absolutely you know also in romania
after 1990 people started to be like
the culture changed so fast people were
really wild almost pushing
everything to an extreme and um
what i found in france more interesting
was um
the respect that i got because still in
romania people
they are so used to kind of being have
too much authority
and tell you what to do too much all the
time and that happened in film school
happened in society
while in france for the first time in my
life i just almost felt like
respect i was respected i was just a
student you know
but i just felt respected and considered
and that was new to me it's not a joni
mitchell song
free man in paris or something like that
i mean i was a free girl
it's probably the first time i really
like i was walking the streets and
really feeling free and not
judged and um you know it's one of those
time that they're like very important in
your life and you really discover
yourself not to sound pretentious but
that really happens
and um it's one of the best periods of
my life
professionally and personally absolutely
then you came to the states uh early
and so how was that in comparison to
having those two different experiences
or actually three
romania during communism romania after
communism and then france
and then you come to what's supposedly
so permissive here
in the u.s with filmmaking how was that
oh
wow um you know for me like i feel
sometimes like i'm this
old person because i keep moving from
one place to another from
um you know different systems and i'm
like god how old i am i'm not that old
you know it's just like i experienced a
lot um in a short time
and i honestly thought because i've you
know been doing a
bit of traveling before coming here in
europe and everything that i would
adjust to us
fast and because of my experience in
france
and that wasn't the case um it took me
longer to adjust
and you know it was a lot of learning a
lot of uh catching up
um also i what's interesting sometimes
about you know
europe versus us and all that it's just
how much people sometimes are scared
here of nudity
of human body of certain things that you
know
you want to show but it's not about
exploiting anything
it's just about showing things how they
happen in life
and people are fine with violence
but they are scared of showing
human humans you know and
love and just you know your body which
for me
that was kind of normal you know even
like especially in
post romania everybody was so like free
and going crazy and you know
going to the other extreme like having
and almost like
naked girls on like the tv guides you
know things that
wouldn't be allowed now even there but
um
[Music]
i was like oh okay this is kind of kind
of strange i thought it's
real freedom but it's still be
conservative
in some ways here in the states
absolutely
yeah i thought it was a big conservative
with
with this aspect and i was talking to
other filmmakers and other people that
they
did admit that they thought that as well
so did you consume a lot of the american
blockbusters finally whether
you were still you know in romania and
you were able to see them and what was
your thought
well you know i did watch some
blockbusters but i'm
a bit of a movie snob you know so
luckily after 1990 we started to have
all sorts of movies
um being distributed one way or another
and i had finally access to
movies i never had access to before but
you know blockbusters i always
watch a bit here and there but that's
not really my cup of tea i have to be
honest with myself
so maybe sometimes in the summer if i
was bored yeah i would see that the
cinema tech was closed and the art house
movies were closed for the summer or
something
um but you know i'm not that
into blockbusters so you went to film
school
in in two places and then you came here
what was your plan
were you going to make your own films or
did you want to somehow at least just be
on a set doing something whether as a
producer
director or something i know didn't have
a plan you know because i know how it's
gonna be i never visited us before
um so i all i wanted was just to be able
to work
in the movie business um and
i was trying to initially because i
didn't have a car it was taking me
longer to get a driver's license and all
that
i was trying to work in an office but
somehow everything i do
everything it happened and every
opportunity i got was either
writing which is great because i love
writing and that's my major
or um working on sets which for me
i love for me that's like one of the
best things about filmmaking
and i always learn and i always have fun
and
so um i was just happy to work period
you know and
um i wasn't i didn't have huge plans in
terms of producing or something like
that no way
do you have any advice for people that
are coming from other countries that
want to come into the film industry and
i know we're in different times now
and it's harder and people are under
more scrutiny
coming in here but in terms of trying to
find a job in the film industry we have
people
on our youtube channel that'll leave
comments about coming over and they're
not sure
just how to approach things even just
just
you know sort of just assimilating to
life here in l.a
you know it's not easy no matter what
time period you come
i'm gonna tell you right now that it's
not easy and you have to be patient and
really try hard
um i think first of all you should be
make sure your english is good
that's has to you know happen and also
progress and talk to people
and improve your english as much as
possible
and and apply like literally i applied
on jobs online and interviewed and
and that's what happened in the same
time people in the movie industry
they're very open
um i never i don't think i had issues
maybe
things i don't know behind the scenes
but i never had issues because i was
from a different country
because you know once you start working
on sets you meet people
there are people from sweden or ghana or
you know people came to me or from
romania or my mother is italian
people you know um have different
interesting family histories here
and uh i think they're very open as far
as i'm concerned i never had
issues um being from another country
but i mean just in terms of things to
know when they come here because it
it can be culture shock for people
coming from san francisco
to l.a absolutely um you know it's
easier now with
having access to internet like when i
first moved here
we had a dial up connection so if my
husband had to make a phone call you
know i couldn't do anything online
um i would say it's
it's totally a different culture look
and there are different times it's
easier now to get around
you know with you know different
services car companies like you know you
don't necessarily even have to have a
driver's license um
to get around la you know i really had
to to learn the city and and um
thomas guide absolutely absolutely and
you get lost and you start crying and
what am i gonna do yeah uh
but it's like i said i think it's easier
nowadays you just have to try to make it
if you make mistakes well just learn
from that you know you're going to make
mistakes
you can't just be prepared 100
as much as you look into things and it's
easier to look into things nowadays
you're still gonna make mistakes that's
how la is
and just learn from that and just keep
going that's
you know that's what i would say just
try to apply for jobs and just be
respectful and
and you know talk to people also don't
just
um when you're on sets talk to people
and
and learn from them and and get friends
that's how you make connections and
that's how people are going to bring you
to other projects if you're good if
you're serious if you put
time and if you're friendly that's
important
what are some common myths about horror
films
i think there are too many probably
um movies they're like kind of done
in the same way or they should be done
in the same way
following a recipe or a certain concept
or
a certain you know because there are so
many subgenres in the holy
in the um horror movies like you know
you have slashers and you have zombies
and
um people tend to kind of do the same
thing over and over again
and i think that's kind of
kind of boring in the same time nowadays
there are people reinventing the genre
and that's something i'm
more interested in doing exploring other
avenues and other ways of doing things
um
also probably people think sometimes
that haraju
is kind of dumb kind of stupid or just
you know kill kill kill and that's all
it is
um but there are so many
interesting movies out there and
nowadays um
people express more things use the genre
to express more things
and um i think it's getting interesting
like hereditary didn't seem like a full
horror film at times it was very
fascinating was more about a family and
there was a
still eeriness to it and then at times
horrific
parts but i really enjoyed that as
someone who's not a total consumer of
horror film
right well i think people are trying to
and they should do um
uh different types of horror movies and
things that
you know either they are based on their
personal experiences
or they um there are things that they
find horrific because
i don't think there are limits and
i think everybody should just
try to do more interesting things that
come
back again and again with the same uh
recipes
for us um you know it's boring to do
the same thing over and over again even
if you know because we make
mostly horror movies so you don't want
to make the same movie
over and over again it is boring you
want to explore other
things you know that time sometimes it
is fun to okay
you know this year i'm making a horror
movie but next year i'm making a zombie
movie but
more than that sometimes you do want to
explore and create
things that you haven't done before or
they haven't been done before
um so when we're doing hiatus and
high def bread directed segment for each
as well
we're trying to see what we can do to
contribute to the genre
and we realize that the best thing to do
is go to our personal experiences
and put them out there so in hiatus we
did this segment called the scout
um that explores a scout that goes wrong
but also the tension between you know an
older director
with you know who's involved with the
younger actress age gap
and um past and present
um in the desert because we wanted to
um i mean i wanted to make a movie in
the desert brad has done that before and
i thought it's also
an interesting backdrop for a horror
movie
because it's harder to see where the
killer comes from because it's such an
open space
and for me it's very american and
visually it's it's stunning um and
for high def we decided to continue with
the uh
filmmaking uh personal based uh
stories so we did um a segment about um
an audition that goes wrong and it's
all and we wrote it together it's um and
this happened before the me too movement
um but because you know we
been working in the industry for a while
we either witnessed
um or things that happened to us we
put them in the segment because you know
it's so much abuse
in the industry not only for women
actually um and
i we think we thought we should address
that of course the audition goes
tragically wrong and horrific but uh we
wanted to it's once again it's about
what human beings can do it to each
other
and it's about pushing the limits of
somebody who wants to succeed to make it
in the industry and how much people can
put up with abuse
so that's you know it's always all sorts
of interesting thing
themes you you you know you want to
explore we just unfortunately
you don't have the time or the money to
do as much as you like to do
because um we always have
um ideas that we want to explore or
explore scripts or
you know things ready to go did anybody
get squeamish about that it's
interesting because people seem to
want to talk about the metoo movement in
terms of outing people but
then when we talk about it as a group i
think a lot of people kind of like
don't want to go there and it's
interesting it's like an elephant in the
room
and it exists but then whether it's
someone who's a willing participant with
it
there's definitely people male and
female that
are willing to go there an agreed upon
relationship
yeah and they're okay with that and it's
just interesting how we it's like we
can't talk about it but then we can out
people on twitter you know it's just
it's very strange i'm not about
necessarily about outing people
and nobody got squeamish i think we
should address certain things you know
because they do
happen they happen to us and um
they're not it's not so much sexual
but it's about human behavior you know
and how we treat each other
and for me coming from romania that was
also very strange and weird to see how
much abuse was in the industry and how
much sexism
i mean i didn't see sexual harassment
but i saw a lot of sexism and
abuse toward like i said were directors
he was so much of use that
i was i was shocked and i think we
should talk about that and
you know um because people need to
know it's not all glamour in hollywood
you know it's just a lot of hard work
and
you do put up with a lot of things in
order to make a movie sometimes
sure and i guess to the the stakes being
so high and people want
so badly for things to turn out whatever
part of the industry they're in yeah
yeah and you know when we're auditioning
actors for
for this part we're talking to actors
and we're asking them you know when
they're reading and all that
we're like is it shocking for you what
do you think
and they were everybody was telling us
no it's not shocking at
all we had have our own stories and this
in you know weird way since kind of real
because okay not all of these situations
there in the script happened to us
but similar things did happen here and
there and everybody had other stories
and
um for us we felt like we're doing the
right thing
to um show a slice of what
is going on in a more like in a fantasy
world but that we created but you know
it's based on reality and it starts real
so it just goes a bit uh in a fantasy
world at some point
do you think name actors are scared to
be a part of horror films
it's a cliche i don't think they're
scared
i think if you um give them a good
meaty role and um
if they like you i think they're not
gonna be
scared now i think uh and because a lot
of people's careers get reinvented that
way
i don't think they are as scared
um we work to name actors like steve
rail's back and you know interesting
people
um and um
they were never snobby about that it's
more about the part
and they just want to make sure that you
are serious about what you're doing
and you do kind of have to prove
yourself
to them which is fine if you know what
you're doing
and you have a plan and um you share
that with them
but other than that frankly we worked
with
most of name actors we work with they
were um
frankly super cool and friendly and
professional and um
you know sometimes of course people get
a bit um
strange about promoting the movie or you
know you do
tend to have some issues here and there
but
you know that's the nature of the beast
and you're just gonna have to take
what's good about the experience and
move on and more important if it's you
know for me what's more important
is that they do a great job with their
part and their
give you a hundred percent in most cases
they give you 100
and some so what do you think about
a director or filmmaker's requirements
that an actor
be part of the promotion you know i
would
i like that i mean i don't think it
should be
like such a requirement that should be
necessarily in the contract or something
i think and it's something i'm dealing
with
and i've been dealing with for a while i
think it should be more like a team
effort
because this is not just my baby it's
everybody's baby
we all put a lot of work into it
um and i think we should try to promote
it as much as possible and work together
on that
and you know sometimes people tend to
move on too fast and they kind of just
leave you and the movie behind and you
know
that's something as a producers we kind
of have to live with it's kind of sad
and sometimes it's disappointing
um but it happens all the time
what advice would you give to josefina
back in 2001
about filmmaking versus now to be less
stressed about
everything in general and
um not overthink so much
everything uh that would be
number one um in the same time
you know looking back um
it's just kind of like you know
hard to um think and
say hey how i would have done things now
because
you know it's kind of kind of too late
but mostly i would say just stress less
what makes you pass on a project
um you know
i don't pass so much on projects because
we initiate them so it's a bit different
uh for us um but you know if people
bring things to me
i just have to be very passionate about
something
in order to do it and i have to feel
like
i'm putting not my entire voice there
but you know because i make
movies with bread i always have um
an input a voice some creative control
um and it's a very collaborative process
so if i can have that then for me
it's just not interesting i'm not just
there to
create a mechanic for somebody just to
make their own movie you know it's just
kind of like i have to be involved
creatively on some level or feel like
that's my baby too
what do you do that you know this is
what i do best and then
the other things i know this is what
brad does best and that's how
you make it work you know it
depends on each situation but yeah there
are things that
you know i know he's better than i am at
you know first of all even he directs
he directs i'm not getting involved in
his shot list he can consult with me and
i can offer him opinions but
i'm not gonna be on set over his
shoulder to tell him to redo a take
or um try to get a different performance
from an actor that's his
uh thing and i totally trust him and you
i think you should trust people because
if you're gonna micromanage everything
everybody's going to get nervous around
you and they're not going to give you
100 and there are things that is better
you know sometimes some creative things
like finding titles
for movies um sometimes conceptual
things
and sometimes promotional things is
better than me and you know
we know when to step back and just let
the other person
um do that and also you know it's the
same with other collaborators that you
know different people that we work with
um i think everybody needs a some
guidance but you just
once you've done that just you know let
them
create and give them a chance to do
something and then
go from there i think if you let people
have some input they're gonna
most of the time come up with something
cool and interesting that you're gonna
like
how does your process work with brad
when you you said you say most of your
projects are like
you know sort of like self-driven or
maybe they come from the two of you
what is it you see something in the news
you have an idea
how does it work it's so different each
time
um you know sometimes it could be
um you know something would get inspired
from going
out you know concert or to a museum or
something an idea
or something that stays with you for a
while i know i want to make a movie
about but i'm not
you know blah blah blah but i'm not sure
so i'm gonna you know
we're taking our time to come up with
ideas it's it's different
each time it's not every project is
different it starts in a different way
um it can come from him or it can come
from me or
um and we just talk and discuss and you
know
um that's kind of how it all starts with
the conversation and go from there see
who's gonna write the script or
he's gonna write on his own or i'm gonna
be involved or
uh because you know i think um
speaking of you know who's better with
certain things than others we know that
so uh you have to be honest with
yourself and um
you know just discuss that and
start start like that we just finished
an anthology film
is that right so then how did that begin
we began high it began with high eight
high def is a sequel of height
height is har um it's a hero ontology
horror independent eight so we had eight
uh interesting you know indie filmmakers
that contributed to a segment
uh to the ontology what happened was
brad actually
met different filmmakers in a facebook
group and everybody was complaining like
i was saying about lack of freedom and
they're kind of
tired of dealing with different
investors and distributors
and different conditions and they're
like you know it used to be fun when
we're making movies when we're kids and
just
running around with a camera with our
friends and doing that so they're like
well why don't we do that now
and they're circulating this idea of
this title high eight started
just with the title more like based on
the format because back in the day they
were shooting on high eight format
so brad came to me and he was like
would you like to do that and i thought
it's just cool and fresh and different
and we've never done that before
and i was like yeah let's let's figure
out a way to do this because it's
complicated you're dealing with people
you never met before
that live in different parts in u.s and
everybody has their own personality
but um let's try to do that and just
that happened really fast we got
all these directors on board and
everything moved on
fast and he was fun and cool and he was
going back kind of like going back and
just making movies with your friends
only this time around you have more
professional experience so you apply
certain rules and you know you have
contracts you
you're professional so you do it like
that and that was a
fun well-received project play different
festivals and got good reviews so we
decided to do the sequel
and for the sequel like i said brad is
usually coming up with titles
but this time around it was my idea hi
death it was my idea because
we're thinking to graduate to a
different format
to hd so we're trying to figure out
title and it just kind of came to me
because it's like high def
it's hd and it's death and it's a you
know it's
kind of like the theme that we're gonna
be using for this entology which
that's what we did each segment has a
theme which is def so every filmmaker
explores the you know theme of the death
in their segment it's just more a
creative way to unify
all the pieces but everybody is doing
something different because once again
they have
creative freedom and we do look at their
scripts
before they start shooting and
everything but we
like i said we don't interfere with that
it's more for
us to know it's like an excitement to
see what everybody's doing
and also to make sure that we don't
repeat certain ideas or concepts or not
everybody's doing
a segment with zombies or something like
that but other than that
and that never happened everybody is
coming up with cool original things
because
what's fun about these segments um
all the filmmakers are coming up with
ideas that they can't
use in like a longer format like a
feature but they're cool and fun to
explore
you know for like 10 minutes or 15
minutes segment or 20 minute segments so
it's just interesting for people to
experiment because you know some
of these filmmakers their fans they have
fans and their fans know them
for you know slashers or zombie movies
or whatever
but they want to do something different
um
and they want to explore things that
they haven't done before and this is the
perfect way to do that
how did you receive submissions for
those scripts like where did you put the
call out was it on this facebook group
um no basically we do choose the
filmmakers we want to work with so we go
to them
first and we ask them hey do you want to
be a part of that and if they accept
that we tell them hey these are our
rules
and then they send us the script once
they have an idea
we have some deadlines but you know like
i said it's not written in stone because
people do
make other movies and we try to work
around their schedules and also
it's good not to rush people so they
have a bit of time
to come up with something interesting
and they send us the scripts after
basically we invite them to
you know join the anthology first time
around we had eight filmmakers
and second time around we had five
because the segments were longer
everybody works with the same kind of
budget it's not a lot but
here it's more about um about doing what
they want to do
how long were the scripts that they were
studying and you said it was 15
minutes segments yeah so it's kind of
like 15 pages or something around there
you know it's interesting because
everybody works differently like
sometimes we dealt with like a filmmaker
who just doesn't write scripts
just sends you a segment it's kind of
like a concept it's like a synopsis
and we don't work like that we just
always have scripts and you know
shot lists and he doesn't do that he
just takes the concept
and goes on set shows it to the actors
and they improvise and
and that's something interesting for us
we're like well we give people creative
freedom we just need to step back
and just let them do that and of course
it's nerve-racking because you hope he's
gonna actually do that
but you know he did and it was great and
fun and
um just kind of have to trust people
even if
they don't work the same way you do so
that's something we kind of learned to
step back and
uh you know give it a shot that's why
you know we don't have big budgets
because
you know you don't know what's gonna
happen
does filmmaking always have to be fun
for you i mean you had said about the
facebook group that the
filmmakers were saying you know what
about when we were kids and we were
creative and free
but then you start to do something after
a while and then the stakes rise and
then
sometimes the fun can be squeezed out of
it how do you keep it fun
well that's kind of hard because you
know we're adults and we do have
responsibilities now and things are
tough for
um for us probably fun
is when we shoot things you know
sometimes it could be in editing
there are moments when that happens and
it's spontaneous
we do try to keep it fun but um
you know and sometimes that doesn't
depend on you because you have
collaborators and they can just
sometimes
drag everything down or they're not fun
or they have bad attitudes or
you know it's not a 100 up to you
you do try to start the project always
with a great attitude and try to
get people with cool attitudes but you
know
you never know everything is different
is different or people's personalities
change you have the same collaborators
working with you
from your previous project all of a
sudden
they're not the same people anymore
there's something changed to them so
you know for us it's um we do try to
have fun
and uh we do try to sometimes from a
concept or on set
but um probably what's for us
always uh what we do like if you had
like a tough day and you're like what am
i doing this
um what am i putting myself for this uh
we always watch movies so at night we
watch a movie
and uh you had a very tough day when you
kind of want to give up
everything and never touch a camera in
your life
and you watch a great movie that you
know you just discovered that night and
you're like well yeah that's what i'm
doing what i'm doing
because i love movies and that gives you
the energy to wake up next day
and continue despite the jerk you dealt
with yesterday or somebody who you might
have to fire even if that's not why you
make movies
or different situations that you have
that you know come up when you make
movies because yeah it's not always fun
anymore you're not in film school you're
not with your friends making movies
anymore so
you deal with different personalities
and budgetary restrictions
and you can't always hire all the right
people that you want or
things can happen all the time so yeah
it's not fun with paperwork and
you know all that i was watching in a
lonely place with um humphrey bogart and
it seems like nothing's really changed
since then i mean in terms of just
you know well what's she done oh a few
indie films you know it just it was like
nothing has really changed in terms of
just how people were sort of
reacting to him and you know his process
as a screenwriter and i just found that
interesting you know
yeah it's it's um it's look it's tough
i'm not saying it's always
easy because it's not it's mostly it's
tough
and you kind of have to have almost like
a
helmet built around you to keep going
but probably that helmet is
the passion that you have for movies and
what they were talking in that facebook
group it's true it's a passion you had
when you were you know
you first started out or you decided
that's what you want to do that has to
still
be somewhere inside you that carries you
through all the struggles that you have
all the time because you know you're
gonna have struggles
no matter how many movies you're making
you know like sometimes
i always think of okay what didn't work
well on the last movie and i'm trying to
prevent that type of situation on the
next one well something
else will happen that will go bad that
you have to deal with and fix
and still finish your movie so it's
it's very uh unpredictable there's so
many things you can't control
as much as you try to prepare things
well
but what carries you through all this or
what carries me
i should say and brad because i can
speak for him too
uh it's the love for movies and what you
do and
sometimes just the creative process
could be fun or sometimes
somebody sends you over the trailer of
your movie and that's what
you know you you were hoping for and
that makes your day and
you know moments like that that totally
make it worth it or
sometimes having a movie selected to a
festival that you didn't necessarily
even apply they just want your movie
because they liked your previous one and
you get the email and you're like
oh that's great that make my day or that
makes
certain things that you're dealing with
worth it
much thought do you put into the trailer
in terms of knowing that
you're going to have people see it
potentially distributors
i don't know if you enter festivals as
well yeah yeah we do festivals
trailer is very important and we
used to literally uh
create a script for that nowadays we're
working with the editor that
is very film savvy and we have
a great report with so we kind of let
him
contribute more and we'd stop to the
script you know
but um we work with him on the trailer
and he gets a lot of the ideas that
um we wanna put out there so he you know
we work with him and it's it's fun but
you know it's tough to trailer for
example the anthologies that we're doing
because you know in the future it's
easier
you have the whole story and you just
kind of think of how you want to
create and what you want to put out
there but here you have different
segments so different stories
so it's more challenging in terms of
trailering
creating a trailer for that because
you wanna uh represent um all the
segments but you have to create a story
out of that
and make it fun for the fans and
put some cool imagery out there so it's
a challenge but for us that's
fun and especially since we work with
somebody who gets it and it's fun to
work with
it's it's fun it's one of the parts of
the process we like a lot
what are some common mistakes you see
filmmakers
do with trailers like you once you see
the film you're like this is actually a
brilliant film
but the trailer didn't sell it for me
well not to give you a different
answer that you know your question
sometimes what i think it's wrong with
people shooting trailers and putting a
lot of money into that
for movies they don't exist just to get
the movie of the ground that's not
i think a good way to get a movie of the
ground
also what i think is a trailer shouldn't
be long
sometimes people kind of have very long
trailers with a lot of
dialogue scenes that's another mistake
i think it should be fast it should show
some
cool imagery and cool lines from your
movie but it should go fast should have
a cool little story
or even if it's not the story of your
movie it's okay don't reveal everything
but
show something there so people can get
an idea of
what the movie is about i mean i don't
think you should
misrepresent your movie uh i think uh
people what you get for the trailer it
kind of should be what
your movie is and you know of course you
don't want to reveal everything i
we never want to reveal everything
especially endings
things like that we try to stay away
from that some people choose to do that
and that's fine
um it's there choice but we don't
like to do that what about revealing
things
in the actual movie how much of it do
you want the audience to see
and how much do you want hidden so is
the audience going to know more
than the character will in most of your
films
um depends on it depends on the movie um
it depends on the movie most of the time
we kind of like
the audience to um discover
things while the character does
so they are kind of more in suspense and
kind of
guessing things while things are
happening
and be more involved that way
how have distribution deals changed from
when you first began
making films distribution changed a lot
period we used to make actually movies
that's how our production company
started we used to make movies directly
for distributors
so that was a different process
then the industry changed a lot and we
basically then we started to do more
like getting
money from investors private investors
and you know make the movie
and then you shop it around and that's
where we're at right now
basically we make the movie then we shop
around see you know who's out there
and also based on your past experience
how you're treated before by other
distributors
um you're kind of like trying to avoid
certain things you know to happen to you
um like what like being screwed
financially
that's a huge one yeah like being
mistreated
by the film by the distributor uh by not
showing you the artwork
of your movie um not
being able to prove that or at least be
involved in that
having your name is spelled on the back
box
on the dvd cover or vhs or like somebody
literally they forgot to put brett's
name
on a movie he directed
on the uh dvd cover on the back but you
know the
guy who did the artwork his name was
there by the director god forbid
should be on the box so you know talking
of abuse
and many issues like that we had a lot
happening
to us so uh we're kind of wary and you
know
sometimes you have you deal with you
know if
we dealt with various companies some
bigger some smaller
and sometimes you deal with bigger
companies and you think you're going to
be in
better hands but not necessarily because
they deal with like a lot of movies and
sometimes they don't get your movie even
if they are acquired and
you know paid for that and then you
struggle
with their promotion department and they
don't get your movie and they don't put
like like
say the laurels from the festivals on
the back cover you fight
to to do that because they want to sell
it as this big blockbuster thing but you
know that people are not going to buy
that because they know
what blockbusters are out there so your
movie it is an indie
you know sci-fi or horror movie and you
want some festivals a word so let's not
be ashamed of that you know but
there are struggles and sometimes how
you're treated you know as a filmmaker
uh you know you don't even get to go
inside the
production company the production the
distribution companies office you're
just more like a production assistant
than
kind of like dropping your deliverables
and they don't even want to deal with
you to pass
by the receptionist uh so you know we
had all sorts of
um situations okay maybe we passed by
when we
recorded the commentary because we had
to you know
but you kind of treated and kind of kept
away
so you know we're working on the last
couple of
movies working with wild eye are
releasing and they are um
distributor in new jersey and usually we
don't work
with distributors who are not in la
because we like to meet with them and go
to their office and all that
but we work with them because
they respect the filmmaker more and
that's important to us they do send us
the dvd covers they do send us a check
disk we have input
we make changes uh we discuss that
with them um and that's frankly how it
should be
but it's not all the time so
what about when it comes to streaming um
what are some things regarding
distribution deals that filmmakers
should be aware of
you should make sure that um
your movie gets on various streaming
avenues nowadays because you have to
although streaming is not generating a
lot of money
for distributor or filmmakers also
it's getting tougher for independent
even independent distributors
and filmmakers even like let's say
amazon they're trying to put more
restrictions
uh about your content like we had to fog
some areas in our move on our last movie
to make sure at least it gets on there
um streaming services and i wasn't happy
at all being from romania
and you know having delta censorship in
the past and that's something
people don't talk about nowadays i think
we definitely need to address that we
don't need that
they're afraid that they can be sued by
you know
parents whose kid clicked on your movie
and they see
whatever because it's a horror movie you
know so you have some violence you have
some nudity whatever
but i don't think because of that i
should
fog or cut scenes from my movie i don't
think it's fair but
in this case it was the only way to get
the movie out there and i
also it it creates um you know some
revenue that we need as in the uh
filmmakers we really need
so that's an issue that uh it just
arrives to us
with this movie it didn't happen
previously
but now it happens also
netflix you know uh when it started
we used to get our movies on netflix
easily once they start to get bigger
they don't accept
a lot of indie movies anymore not just
horror movies
they don't just accept that period so
it's kind of frustrating because they
build their company on movies like ours
like our older movies they're you know
part of their services
our newer movies aren't and that's just
not
fair you know because then they build
their business
on small movies like us when you know
studios wouldn't deal with them because
they know who they were
and then they got bigger and bigger and
sure now they make their own productions
they don't care anymore
so you know streaming is important but
it's it's tough they have a lot of
quality control like i think
itunes it's very tough about that like
almost too tough
and it's very hard on indie filmmakers
you know because it's it's a very
expensive process to get a movie on like
let's say itunes because it cost
us and the distributor a lot of money
and i don't know if i would make
my money back if i you know give it to
them necessarily but just to go through
the process
to be accepted it's very expensive so
you know uh streaming it's still kind of
a complicated issue
we still believe in um
you know dvds and blu-rays and
even vhs high-def even came like limited
vhs because
there are a lot of collectors out there
and
a lot of uh horror fans are collectors
and they're supportive
and frankly that's what generates more
money than streaming just like physical
media
still even if a lot of video stores are
closed and retail stores are closed
at least you know from various um
sites they can buy you know the dvd and
that generates
more money than actually streaming
so with the the fogging of of the things
in the movie are we talking labels and
and brands or this is like
male full frontal or something yeah it's
it's
what's fogging uh we had to fog is male
full front or women full front not a lot
because i didn't have a lot obviously
but um yeah it's about nudity it's not
about
brands because we wouldn't have that to
begin with that's something i make sure
as a producer we don't have that
um and i i'm very um
kind of nagging the field producers of
all these segments not to have that
and if we would have that we would deal
with that we would
first digitally remove it or you know do
something or have them reshoot something
so that wouldn't even
get there but no for me it's it's
literally we're getting to a state of
censorship
of you know um basically somebody we
gave
artistic control now he had parts of his
segment
fogged so i'm not happy about that he
wasn't
the director wasn't happy about that
because none of us
knew that would happen but you know he
understands obviously he wants his movie
out there
and that happened onions only on
streaming on dvd vhs
we have no problem because a distributor
doesn't care he's very
cool otherwise you know he went upset in
the movie in the first place he knows
what these movies are and he loves the
genre and he's very cool and supportive
so he's not the one creating
the problem at all he was annoyed to
tell me about
this new thing with amazon so yeah
and it's is it only amazon or the other
as far as i know
right now it's just amazon but
i don't know like it's something very
new and
to be honest with you other filmmakers
we know uh didn't have this experience
yet
so i'm kind of like trying to almost
talk about it so maybe you'll stop at
some point
if we bring it up you know and discuss
that this is
um an issue that we started to get
concerned with recently because of this
movie and this situation
also i'm not thrilled with you know
piracy in general
because that really um
you know kills us financially and it's
very hard nowadays to make foreign sales
and everything because of
piracy so it's a major concern and it's
something the industry didn't do
anything about for years
so that's very problematic and i guess
you know big studios
they're you know they lose some money
but they don't care
uh enough about that and even if they
have offices full of lawyers they don't
do anything
but we as independent filmmakers were
really affected by that because we lose
a lot of foreign sales and
i mean i had to shut down things on
youtube people putting our movie
illegally on youtube many times a
distributor had to do that too
i had to shut down here and there are
some torrent sites but you know i can't
do that every day i can't
chase these things every day or
otherwise i'm not going to make movies
anymore you know i mean i don't have a
room full of lawyers doing that you know
who are
hired on staff paid to do things like
that
i just do it myself and you know it's
kind of negative
and it's not something you want to do
every day here and there
look i'm gonna do it because you know
we're losing money i don't want my movie
on youtube who just came out or
something for everybody to watch it for
free
when they can just buy a copy or stream
it on various
you know venues that are out there so
yeah
do you send an email to the um content
creator first i mean i realize it's your
your ip that they've stolen but do you
try to at least give them one chance
because i find it's interesting people
they'll fight you back on it like no
i'm not taking this down you're like
wait a minute what gives you the right
to have our i don't deal with people who
put it out there
oh you just i just go to youtube or
whoever
and just write them i have like a
literally um
a document already written and i just
copy and paste it and i just send it
they do take it down yeah they are
responsive if you reach out to them
but you have to do it and you don't
always have time to check on youtube see
if your movie is illegally there you
know but sometimes if you do
and i just do it right away because i
just you know have a document i just
copy and paste it and send it
immediately and it usually gets down
because i have
it's my movie i have proofs only unless
you know
my production company or the distributor
you know they're the only entities who
could
do something with it do the two of you
create stories for the market
i know that's a big dilemma when you
make a movie you know you kind of have
to consider
a lot of things um because you don't
just make it for yourself
you have to consider the fans what they
like
you do think of what's trendy but you
know you also know till you're gonna
finish
post-production whatever is trending now
it's not gonna be trendy in a year
so you kind of have to almost take a
chance what we do lately is just kind of
take a chance and do some things that we
think they're original
they haven't been made before it's not
just trendy
because if it's trendy you just have to
do it fast and that's a machine that's a
factory and we just don't do that
other companies do that that's great we
don't do that
so then we're just kind of going more on
our guts and what we know about the
genre
we get inspired from various movies from
different time periods
uh what we know fans like and uh what we
like to do
to contribute and like i said you just
sometimes just take a chance and see
what people
they like it or not but you have to put
something out there that
you like and you hope other people will
like but
we do always think of fans of other
people
and you know you do think you want your
movie to be easily
marketed to have something new and fresh
and brings a new original concept you
don't you want it to stand out
in the crowd because a lot of people are
making movies a lot of competition out
there
so you don't want your movie to be one
of the whatever new slasher movies or
you know okay it's
zombie movies are popular okay let's
make one of those we don't want that
we're trying to
create whatever your budget is sometimes
you have more money sometimes you
don't but you're trying we're trying to
do something more original and
contribute and make it stand out
you do kind of especially brad is very
good about like the tile make sure it
hasn't done before it's cool it's new
it's fresh
concept sometimes we come up with the
artwork before the script is even
finished
just to create something that you know
we haven't done we haven't seen before
and just makes your movies stand out
because
speaking of distribution and festivals
they want things that stand out it's
easy easier for them to
market things if you know what you're
doing and you bring them something more
interesting
and different so a theme i'm picking up
is that you
you like to do things that are new and
that you haven't done before you don't
want to
be regurgitating sort of the same thing
again no because we started by doing
that
and uh you do a lot of programmers or
things like that and
look there are fun and you have to make
a living
and you try even those to contribute
things
but you know lately we're kind of like
look
you know we're not getting any younger
and you just want to contribute
more than you know just make a movie
that is like
100 other movies we're just trying to do
things are more interesting for us to
explore um
that we haven't done before because you
know okay slasher it's good
fun but and you know bread is known for
some slashers and everything and i'm not
saying i'm not gonna do that ever again
but if i would do it
once again i would try to you know break
the tradition
come up with something different just
you know just keep people guessing and
also make it more fun and interesting
than the same
thing over and over again i mean you
know it's boring i think for everybody
so once you finish a project how much
time
do you give yourself in between or you
don't do you give yourself like a
resting period
to kind of rejuvenate or no because it
must take a lot out of you
it does it does take a lot of us because
we're like you know guiding a project
for years
um ideally that would be nice to
have a break but that doesn't always
happen most of the time it has doesn't
happen like
right now we have high def coming out
and we're already working on the next
movie
so prepping different things you know um
so you know it just kind of happens uh
because you know in the same time some
projects are gonna drag longer in post
or something so at least till you get to
the point that you
get them in the can you're trying to get
things going
as much as possible not let the momentum
going either
you know because things tend to take
longer than you'd like to sometimes so
it's better to get
on on it but ideally yeah that would be
nice to have a bit of a break but that
like i said that doesn't always happen
it's not even if you're in charge you're
not
it's not always you know up to you and
every movie it's
it's different has its own journey you
know sometimes you know we used to make
movies for distributors when we were
doing that they had a release date set
already so before we
even shooting when you won't be coming
out so you really can't
drag your feet to that nowadays we don't
do that but
in the same time we do kind of set
ourselves some sort of deadline because
otherwise things are never going to get
finished um so with high def we had like
a festival deadline
it wasn't like no we didn't have to be
like completely
finished finished in post but at least
get to a certain phase to be
acceptable to present to a festival
because otherwise
people can keep dragging things and you
know
slow down the process so i think we all
need deadlines but yeah in an ideal work
i will world i would like to have
a few breaks in between definitely
at what point do you think a filmmaker
is ready to take on investors
you know you're never ready you just
have to just start to do it
you know just just have have the chance
um just take the chance or try you know
you can't just wait for somebody to let
you do something
or you know sure you do have to be
prepared you can just
come out of film school and not have any
experience and
think you're gonna you know get a lot of
money to make a big movie or something
but i think it's good to work on sets i
think it's good to gather experience
because when you get in a meeting with
investors they'll know that you know
what you're talking about
and that's i think it's important but um
i don't think you're ever ready i think
at some point you should just
take a risk and just go for it and see
what happens
because i don't think it's good to wait
forever
for um things to happen you're never
ready
uh people can you know think of oh i
still need more money to make my movie
and still have some money that you know
i
got already in the bank but i'm still i
still need more
um they always want everything to be
perfect and
as much as you try it's not gonna be
perfect but it's better just to go and
do it
and you learn from that and you'll have
a movie then just wait for years to get
a bit more money and you'll never make
a movie so i think it's better just to
like sometimes just take the chance and
go for it
i mean when i first started to produce i
mean was i ready i don't know i mean
pardon me up i i was and i was i thought
i was but i wasn't like overthinking it
you know i already
had some experiences learned some things
and you just kind of have to go and do
it but you know
when you know our first day of shoot um
you know we scouted the location big
time it was a river going through it all
of a sudden it was a lot of rain from
our last
scout and it was a river going through
uh the area that we had to like and
almost build a bridge to carry equipment
to go to the woods we needed to shoot
well was i prepared for that no i wasn't
but you just sometimes just to kind of
roll up your sleeve and
that's what's called filmmaking you just
kind of have to be very flexible
and you know learn how to deal with
every situation no i was not prepared
for that it's not what i thought i'm
going to be doing that day
but so what you know movie got finished
so that's why it matters and it makes
for a
funny story now even if it was really
stressful back then
can you take us back to the first time
that you pitched an investor
probably um that was like in 2006 or
something
uh we're trying to get a bigger movie of
the ground
and brad was writing some specs for this
production company that was
out of state they never produced a movie
they're just kind of
investing in scripts and we're like well
maybe
you should actually ins you know they're
you should try to make a movie instead
of just putting so much money in
development
so we knew about a cool place um that
was kind of like a
stage in the valley that had some
built-in sets kind of sci-fi
looking and brent had a concept already
for what he wanted to do there
and like a sci-fi interesting horror
movie so we went over there and we
videotaped um kind of did like a tour of
the place of the facility of the sets
so that together with the script was
kind of like a
package to pitch
kind of give them an idea what they can
get
but even that you know they they like
the script and they liked the place and
they got the idea that we could do
something for lower budget but
interesting but even that took years to
probably over a year
to get all the financing because my
initial budget
which was also part of the pitching
package
um i mean we didn't get that as much
money as would have liked to initially i
was budgeting for like a 35 millimeter
to shoot on that longer schedule over
three weeks or something
but you know sometimes like i said what
you get you work with what you have
so uh based on how much they gave us
i had to reconfigure everything and shot
on hd and you know had a
shorter schedule than you know but we
we managed to do that you kind of have
to rethink everything
and you know um have almost like a plan
b
and that's our movie players that we did
in
we shot in 2006 or seven
what are some signs to an investor that
a filmmaker is ready
to take on you know some people they
just trust you
you know just from like i don't know
um like you know from like your previous
work
um and some people are gonna question
you and
challenge you no matter
your experience and i think
that um you know you kind of have to be
prepared for both
you know because you never know what
you're gonna get
um but i think more experience you have
the better but you know when you start
out you're not gonna have so much
experience but um maybe
uh partner yourself with a producer or a
lime producer or you know
a few people who have more experience
than you and you can trust
to maybe you know help you out to get
something bigger
on the ground and also help in a meeting
with investors and so on
for me i felt as a woman was always
tough
being in a room like i was the only
always the only woman in the room
and i'm from another country and we're
married and have an accent
so it's always it was always a challenge
to like i always had to prove myself
again and again and again even if by
that point let's say
you know especially the players by that
point i produced some
some features i had some of these
investors come to visit our set so they
see how we work and the way you know
they knew were
completing movies were you know on
schedule on budget
sometimes with some people it could be
never enough and some people they just
trust you right away so you know
sometimes it's a matter of luck
who you meet and how they treat you and
everything like
you know everybody has different
experience but with me was
either very easy like yeah sure okay who
is she okay fine
or like i have meeting after meeting
after meeting after meeting and
you know but still hopefully
at the end you'll get the money to make
the movie because sometimes you meet
with people and things never happen
that's a lot of time wasting
and that's why sometimes we got fed up
like that's why we made high eight
because we're two meetings for
a couple of years to get bigger movies
of the ground
and it was economic crisis
and everything and people are very wary
and even if we made a movie that was
bigger budget and successful and
everything
and we got tired of waiting and all
these meetings and things were not
happening and agents
and and we're like we what do we do here
wasting time we're filmmakers we make
movies so
you know who cares what budget we have
let's just take a camera
and go because this is years of your
life that you're not productive and for
us
that's not acceptable
but there's a big difference between
somebody identifying someone
or identifying with someone or liking
them versus someone being competent i
mean i could meet a million people that
hey i'd want to be best friends with but
they're not competent how would you
prove that you're confident that you can
deliver when you say you will because
sometimes you just get a feeling about
somebody and maybe they're not really
your kind of person but you're like
this person's got competent and they're
going to come through for me and i can
tell well i think everybody has a track
record
you know and sometimes your movies do
speak for yourself
you know i have your body of work and
also how i prepare
you know if you see i'm prepared and i
have solutions and i have a budget
and i and all these things that i
personally bring i don't know what other
people do but i bring them from
experience and from
what i've done before you know but um
i you know i don't mind answering
questions obviously i always do
and i always have a plan for you know
how i would pull that movie off and i
share it with people and tell them how i
would approach that
um you know if they trust me or not i
don't know
you know but um i think if you're not
prepared then that's a problem
you're not gonna have a chance if you're
prepared yeah you might have a chance
you know what sometimes we know and it's
annoying people filmmakers get money
from god now some rich relative or
something they don't have to prepare for
anything like you go through meetings
and you go through
a lot of proving yourself even if you
made movies and your movies sold out and
sold in different territories and you
know people made money off your work and
you can prove that with numbers like
brett had um
one of his movies was like the best
seller of a certain
uh distribution company they it was a
title itself
sold the most so i think just that right
there it's a great
um at least entry if not a way to
convince somebody to give you money
but some people they just get money
because whatever you know and
that's something that uh you kind of
have to get used to in the business that
you know not everything is fair but you
just have to
do your thing
do you have a pre-production checklist
absolutely
we always start with the schedule the
budget
with looking for locations locking
locations
as you know soon as you can because
that's
very important um for us in general for
a movie if you don't have the right
location
then you're in trouble and i don't think
that's something you need to leave for
last minute
and then we start to do casting and
casting process and then crewing up
and obviously you always set a date
ahead of time hey this is when i like to
shoot so if you have the location locked
uh you
kind of set the date by you know making
a deal and
unlocking that and sure that can be
stressful because you already put some
money down and you
you know rented something but in the
same time you kind of can't stop that
stop that train from from going so yeah
we do casting
that's something that we take seriously
and also
you either call your people you work
with or you know interview
people for other positions different new
collaborators and
that's how we do it once we cast we do
rehearsals and meet with you know
department heads
before the shoot and make sure
everything is in place
and we're available to everybody
24 hours a day for questions and
meetings and we try to
like i said we try to have as many
things
locked in place as possible but you
always have to be flexible for
things that can come up somebody can
drop last minute it's always something
like that
that's why i you know always have more
resumes around
because you never know you might have to
replace last minute or something can
fall through you know we like to prepare
as well as possible but
things will happen no matter what it's
the nature of the beast
right so when you find the location how
much time
are you giving yourself once you lock
that location in for then
you know you have to do casting crew up
all these different things
for this shoot date you know that
depends too on the location
sometimes you know if it's the desert
and it's like something
uh more open like that or a theater in
town that you kind of can
you know work with them but like it's
you know easier to book let's say in
advance maybe you have like a couple of
months at least
but i remember like on a feature we did
this feature players i was telling about
the stages that you know we videotaped
for the
pitch packaging and everything once we
finally got the money from the investors
my
first you know phone call was to them to
book the stages i remember i was trying
to shoot in the summer and it was kind
of like in springtime when i was calling
well the stages are not available till
the rest of the year i thought i'm gonna
have a heart attack i'm like i'm gonna
lose the money from the investors if i
don't shoot by the end of the year
so all this like all of a sudden big
networks they were like
they booked the place so i finally
got something finagled something with
them to shoot in october which was fine
gave us more
time to prep because we're building sets
and mini chores and costumes and
everything
it was a lot of prep to do so in
retrospect that was kind of like a
blessing in disguise
because it gave us more prep work but
that determined
everything so it's not always up to you
you know you're dealing with different
situations so that kind of
increased our um you know
prep time but that was good in that case
but usually around a couple of
months i would say but you know
obviously depends on each movie you know
um how much you have to do if it's
period or if it's
set in the future if it's contemporary
we have a bit less
uh time to prep it because it's you know
a tad easier especially if you have
outdoor locations where locations are a
bit easier to get
do you ever cast a movie without locking
in the location
no i don't think so no
or at least have an idea of what i might
yeah yeah yeah because it's kind of
those hands and hands you don't want to
waste people's time and tell them what
in the audition i need you
because when we audition people we kind
of know when we're going to be scheduled
or scheduled to shoot so we tell people
dates like we need you these days
who even put that in the ads are you
available
because we don't want to waste anybody's
time you know different people
have different commitments and we you
need to be prepared and let people know
in advance so they can clear the
schedules and everything
so that's kind of how it works in
addition we already
tell them a date of some sort so we
we know looking back on it now
why are you still here working in
hollywood
because i'm crazy um
because i love to make movies more than
anything else and i still
i still think i'm gonna keep doing that
because that's what i like and
i don't know what else to do period
what what are the stories you want to
still tell
what do you want to be involved in
um things that create a universe usually
i'm always interested in that a movie
that creates a universe
a world that we create and that's
something that i'm interested in
and things that comment on
what's going on or you know reinvent
um genres or sub genres
things that disturb people i like to
make edgy movies
i know that because maybe because i'm a
woman or something i don't know what
people expect of me i know
back in romania i was more like okay
maybe you're a woman i'm going to be
making movies for
kids or you know sappy dramas or
something well i'm not interested in
that i've never been interested in that
i love to make edgy movies that disturb
people on some level
and get them out of their comfort zone
and
that's what i like to do where does that
come from
because i'm different and weird and uh
whatever people
expect of me i'm not i think
um and i just think that movies
are great to entertain people and it's
you know
great way to escape i do that too
but also i think it's a way for people
to
bring interesting observations and start
conversations
as well so i like to probably start the
conversation by disturbing and
get people going and talking about it
but not just to shock just for the sake
of shocking
but just to create a conversation about
we'll see
was there a point where you had to come
to terms with the fact that you didn't
want to do
sappy love stories or kids movies where
you embrace the fact that
okay i'm weird and i'm okay with that
i've always been like that
yeah i always had an independent spirit
and i don't
want to let people to tell me what to do
or when to
you know allow me to make a movie or
whatever i just go and do it and i
that's how i am so um i don't think
me and brad will react well to people
telling us what to do
so that's kind of how we are and we're
just gonna do things the way we do
things
yeah and i've always been like this so
since you like to um you know sort of
stir the pot with conversation it sounds
like there has to be a point to why
you're disturbing someone
it's not just for shock value have
people commented after screenings and
been fascinated by it yeah absolutely
are we you know
if we have a screening or if we can do
that we can attend a festival and they
have a q a
people always come and ask questions and
um
it's always a conversation sometimes you
know um
we kind of have to go because they have
to close the screening room or you know
our time expire but
yeah people uh you know are you know are
always interested in
finding out more and why and um
what's the reason behind something and
that's
um i think they i think we should
discuss that and talk about it we're not
just
making something shocking just for the
like i said just for the shock value
everything has a meaning and something
behind it and
um it's interesting to get people's
opinion or take about things too like
what
okay make a shocking segment for an
anthology but what do they find shocking
in that and
see what they think and sometimes what
they think is not what necessarily you
thought when you wrote it or produced it
or whatever but it's
interesting to take their opinion in
consideration and see what they got
out of that that's for us it's one of
the
you know most um i don't know most fun
you can have by talking to people and
get people's reactions and see what they
thought and what
their take on it is because i can be
something you
you know kind of lives with you when you
leave the um
screening room kind of stays with you
and something you think about
and uh i don't know it's it's for us
it's not just making movies for the sake
of movies you do like i said always
think of an audience and it's nice to be
able to interact and get their
take on it what was some of the feedback
you
received recently you know for us with
the ontologies especially
it's interesting to see what people's
favorite segments
are and why and um
it's always different um some people
like more segments
one segment some people don't like that
segment at all
so you know it's kind of like um
something new for
us and we're just because we're the
executive producers
also we're very um interested in
everybody's opinion and their take
and it's something new for us because
you know each segment is directed by
different
filmmakers so we are kind of
also trying to be very um
[Music]
uh how can i say this you know they
they're from makers sometimes they get
feel back as well
you know they read the reviews and some
they get upset that somebody didn't like
their segments so we're a bit kind of
like their
parents or psychologists and like we're
like well it's okay
they didn't like it but this review
liked it and you know it's not about
that
it's about you expressing what you
wanted to express we're always here to
to support that so it's something new
for us this time around because we kind
of
also have to deal with filmmakers and
you know artists are sensible
sensitive we understand that and we're
kind of
trying to be more mature about it as
well
you